في مجتمعاتنا العربيه الكريمه قد يذهب
البعض عن جهل وحب وربما تعاطف ان يدفعك
لتناول بعض الاطعمه المحظوره عليك ويقول
انا متاكد بان القليل لن يضر هذه العباره
تشكل خطرا مباشره على المصابين بالحساسيه
ضد بعض الاطعمه وقد تكسر تعايشه معلومه
ومن انواع الحساسيه التي سنتحدث عنها
حساسيه بيوتن لان الواقع يؤكد ان القليله
من الجلوتين يمكن ان يكون سيئا جدا لشخص
مصاب بها واذا كنت لا تعرف حساسيه
الجلوتين فبكل بساطه هي اضطراب هضمي يحدث
نتيجه تناول بروتين الجلوتين ويؤدي غالبا
الى تلفا في الامعاء الدقيقه يوجد بيوت
غالبا في القمح والشعير ولا يستطيع
المصابون هضمه تابع المزيد عن الجلوتين
الثالث
الجلوتين مركب بروتينيه موجود بشكل طبيعي
في بعض الحبوب مثل القمح والشعير والشوفان
ويعاني البعض من مشاكل الهضميه وصحيه
ناجمه عن تناوله مما يسبب نوعا من
الحساسيه تسمى بحساسيه الجلوتين او حساسيه
القمح المعوي ويعرف طبيا بمرض السيليك
ويبدو ان المرض في زياده حيث يقدر
الباحثون نسبه الاصابه به في العالم الى
واحد بالمئه وتتراوح نسبه حدوث هذا المرض
في المملكه لدى الاطفال ما بين نصف الى
واحد في المئه اما لدى البالغين فيتراوح
ما بين واحد الى اثنين ونصف في المئه
وبناء على ذلك قامت وزاره الصحه السعوديه
باطلاق برنامج التامين المجاني للمنتجات
الخاليه من الجلوتين حيث يهدف هذا
البرنامج الى توفير المنتجات الغذائيه
الخاليه من الجلوتين للمرضى بعض التشخيص
الطبي هو التدريب الكوادر على احدث الطرق
العلميه للتعامل مع مرضى حساسيه الجلوتين
حيث يبلغ عدد المستشفيات التي تقدم الخدمه
43 مستشفى التابعه لوزاره الصحه السعوديه
ويبلغ عدد المستفيدين من هذا البرنامج
اليوم اكثر من اربعه الاف في مستفيد
على كل من الرياض ينضم لنا استشاري امراض
الجهاز الهضمي والكبد والتغذيه للاطفال
دكتور بدر سليم دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
معنا صباح العربيه يعني هناك انطباع عالمي
بان حساسيه الجلوتين في ارتفاع عالميا ما
اسباب ذلك دكتور
اهلا وسهلا صباح الخير صباح الخير على
الجميع المشاهدين العربيه
واسم دارج ولكن للاسف هذا الاسم خاطئ
والاسم همم باللغه الانجليزيه هو مرض
السيلياك وهمم
اللغه العربيه ممكن ترجمتها الى همم
حساسيه القمح المعوي همم
احس ان هذا الترجمه قد تكون انها اقرب
وتفرق بين حساسيه القمح العاديه وحساسيه
القمح همم المعوي والمقصد فيها مرض همم
سيليا همم وهو همم مرض يعني همم عباره عن
مرض مناعي همم التهابي همم يحدث في همم او
يصيب بالامعاء الدقيقه نتيجه اكثر هذه
الامعاء دقيقه بماده الجلوتين وماذا
البروتين موجود في القمح والشعير وهمم همم
همم يعني
والشوفان همم
نتيجه تعرض همم
المريض اللي هذه المواد همم بشرط ان يكون
لديه همم قابليه للاصابه بهذا المرض تحدث
الاصابه بهذا المرض الدكتور
همم اهم غذاء في العالم الى اكبر مصدر
للحساسيه
همم من همم الامراض يعني مرتبطه او هناك
العديد من الامراض همم الاكل همم الجلوتين
هو عباره عن بروتين ودائما حساسيه او همم
ان امراض الحساسيه بشكل عام همم هي عباره
عن تحسس اللي معده البروتين الموجوده في
اي نوع من الاكل يعني مثلا شخص مصاب حسيه
مثلا همم
ماده البروتين الموجوده في هذه همم المواد
في هذه المرض يعني مكتشف من همم
زمان
والان يعني بدا يعني همم يزيد همم تشخيص
همم الحالات يعني في خاصه في السعوديه
وزياده الامراض الوراثيه همم عفوا الامراض
المناعيه همم لها علاقه همم قويه بهذه
المرض فادى الى ظهور هذا المرض والتسجيل ب
همم
اكثر من السنوات همم السابقه
دكتور هل هي حاله مرضيه يمكن للشفاء منها
ام انها حال ابديه تستمر مع المتحسسين
لا للاسف همم
مرض السيلياك هو مرض يعني مدى الحياه همم
للاسف ويلزم المريض تجنب جميع المنتجات
التي تحوي على ماده همم الجلوتين همم في
الوقت الحاضر لا يتوفر اي ادويه كان هناك
همم هناك الكثير من الادويه لكنها ما زالت
في طور تجارب وفي المرحله الاولى والمرحله
همم ثانيه كان هناك همم واحد من ادويه في
المرحله الثالثه وكان متوقع انه يعني همم
ينتهي ان شاء الله من المرحله الثالثه في
نهايه العام همم 2022 لكن توقفت همم
وجدت ان نتائج يعني غير همم
الفرق المامون طيب هذا بالنسبه ايش في ما
يتعلق بالادويه والعلاج دكتور بدر اما في
التشخيص هل حساسيه الجلوتين زادت اصلا
يعني وتحولت هذه الظاهره الى مرض متفشي
اكثر فينا ام ان تشخيص هو الذي زاد هو طرق
التشخيص
اتوقع انا
كل سببين يعني بشكل عام هناك ازدياد في
الامراض المناعيه همم بالعالم وهذا المرض
يعني مرتبط همم بالامراض همم المناعيه هي
بشكل يعني عام زياده الامراض المناعيه همم
سوف تزيد من نسبه همم لصعبه مرض همم
سيليك بالاضافه الى زياده الوعي همم في
المجتمع همم السعودي همم
وتوفر الامكانيات لتشخيص همم هذا همم
المرض في العديد يعني من همم المناطق
والمستشفيات ادى الى زياده همم لكن لا
نستطيع نجم الا اذا تم دراسه همم
انتشار المرض هذا بعد عده سنوات ومقارنه
بالنتائج الموجوده همم ممكن يعني الواحد
يعني همم يعني همم يستطيع الاجابه على
هذا السؤال شكرا جزيلا حدثنا من الرياض
استشار امراض الجهاز الهضمي والكبد
والتغذيه للاطفال الدكتور بدر سليم شكرا
دكتور